i tried running too
it doesn't work it always follows all
due respect that's your life not mine
i'm not so sure about that what do you
want from me lady hey watch your tone
new girl
you know how they always say it goes
back to the original
here's the original
i want your help
because you're wrong this is your life
now which means that whoever this is is
gonna keep coming for you so so i want
you to help us kill him you want me to
help you and
the host of a morning show commit murder
hey
if you can't beat them join them that's
courtney cox and neb campbell in the new
scream and we are here along with david
our kids
all right before we go that's the final
slide
all right
i'm gonna ask each one of you quick
rapid fire questions david worst habit
during the movie drinking has been the
worst havoc
thank goodness
what was your worst habit during the
movie
we were staying in the doubletree hotel
and they had cookies on the pillowcase
every day and i ate those cookies every
single day
uh courtney what was your worst habit
during the movie
i wonder if i smoked then i probably did
did it yeah uh smoking cigarettes
david
what is the scariest thing about you
well i beat myself up you know i'm just
very critical of myself and
that's the toughest thing
nev what's the scariest thing about you
i'm canadian there's not a whole lot
scary about us
i don't know
uh
yeah i don't know honestly
well i think gumbaz no i think that
mine would be
my critical voice maybe not in the same
way
um
you know dealing with as i get older and
all the other things you do to criticize
yourself as opposed to just accepting
that would probably be the scariest and
worst david have you ever seen a ghost
in real life
i don't know i feel the energy sometimes
but
uh i don't think i've seen a ghost in
real life
nav
there was a house that i owned the very
first house i owned that someone passed
away in and um i was not the only person
to have
experiences in that house
courtney have you ever seen a ghost in
real life
i haven't seen a ghost but i did live in
a house that i um was believed to be
haunted i answered the door one day
and uh there was a ups guy or a you know
fedex person there and and they said do
you know that your house is haunted and
i go well i've heard that but why it
goes because there's someone standing
behind you
dude that's a good scare good one that's
a really good swim okay last question
how did this movie change you david
we had had a daughter out of it and you
know she's the greatest thing in my life
and and
yeah so that really is
the most
impactful thing that's ever happened to
me in this business yeah
nev how did this movie change you
ah i mean this movie gave me everything
it was a springboard i think for all of
us i mean it really its success really
helped pave the way for all of us in our
careers and um my life would be very
very different without scream
yeah i hear you on that
courtney how did this movie change you
well besides the obvious um i
will not go to the bathroom in
a movie theater or just about like any
sports doesn't matter
i always look underneath and
prefer just not to go i will not go into
a parking lot by myself and if i do my
heart is racing and i'm constantly
looking
okay i'm so honored to be
a part of this journey with you guys and
i congratulate you with all of my heart
um also everyone in our studio audience
is going to go home with this 4k ultra
hd
dvd because it's out for the very first
time like this thank you to paramount
home
[Applause]
screen
entertainment
premieres this friday january 14th
and we'll be right back
[Music]
you